we always seem to end up back to
basically us with something a little bit
different spock for example
did he always have a ball cut i think he
always had a bit of a bowl
yeah a lot of nimoy's bowl yeah yeah
yeah
predator is a guy in a suit
spock a guy with roles he is then of
course we've got the archetypal alien
in every case it's basically a humanoid
body shape
[Music]
all of these seem to lack a bit of
imagination to me looking at them from
an evolutionary perspective
there's going to be some rules i think
it's going to be carbon based microbes
are going to be important we're going to
see natural selection and evolution if i
could make one bet about alien life it
would be on that it would evolve and i
don't think i would lose this pet
[Music]
very great thickness of ice about 10
miles i think and underneath we've
seemingly got good evidence that there
is liquid water i think it's all heated
by these volcanic vents
which is looking a little bit similar to
the sorts of things that we find in the
deep ocean here on earth we know there's
going to be no sunlight getting down so
i mean they're going to have to be
chemosynthetic
[Music]
the bacteria would maybe
at some point start to form
symbioses larger cells and then you
would have maybe the
beginnings of multi-cellular life
because this is a unstable planet
any kind of life around these vents
needs to have a mobile form it has to be
able to abandon ship and find find new
events to live on i mean let's imagine
we find something like this tadpole
creature
it doesn't have eyes because it's
dark but he does have some way of
sensing heat
let's imagine this guy is actually
the first morph of a more complex
organism maybe you would see him
metamorphosizing
he is now turning into his real form a
kind of chemosynthetic
large worm
he takes root actually so he's attaching
just like the lava of a sea squirt that
we find here on earth yeah yeah these
mobile forms that can go out find new
habitat and then start the whole thing
all over again
he's using his tentacles as gardens to
cultivate these bacteria and to charge
his metabolism
when this probe lands in 15 years we
might be proven right something like
this might be down there
[Music]
when trappist is orbiting its sun it
stays tidally locked which means the
same face is always facing the sun one
side is getting absolutely baked and
whilst the other side gets no light at
all it's very cold and that line where
sun meets shade this terminator as it's
called is the zone where life might just
about be able to exist on trappists like
a long thin island of life
one side is always sunny on one side is
always dark so that would imply constant
winds flowing one direction
what pass off as trees could be like
weather rains
you can see this effect on earth
actually if you go to the edges of
cliffs
you know with that strong wind blowing
it's going to be quite difficult for
these animals to make themselves heard i
think the animals display
maybe among the trees you see something
red fluttering about like a kite this
kind of quasi-bird-like
animal with a very long kind of snout
and he uses it to hold on to the tree
what he then does is open up his
wings he's trying to attract her mate
yeah he's trying to impress his
potential girlfriend here
very colorful world yeah yeah but a very
focused and intense world so imagine a
line of predators that always stalk from
the direction of the sun
maybe he would have six limbs other than
four which gives you a huge advantage
for hanging on and
clambering around there's no reason at
all why this animal couldn't have an
extra joint giving it a little bit more
range of movement more flexibility
because with that lower gravity it's not
taking such a strain
raptorial yes yeah exactly to grab and
hold
and it kind of gives it a huge range
watch your back yes
very high gravity is going to be a big
issue everything is kind of flattened
out maybe one
form
could be like this flattened slug
creature
flatworm sort of creature
you could have a huge variety of these
guys
given that the planet's been around for
two billion years longer than earth has
might we find the evolution of
intelligent life because of the size
constraints i think intelligent life
would begin from a colonial perspective
just like a group of ants collaborating
together
if you were to see these guys they would
look like very intelligently guided
swarm of little shapes moving across the
floor and coming towards you maybe they
would form different shapes or letters
trying to communicate the idea of all
these subunits these little individual
things coming together and creating not
just a colony but something that's got
intelligence and can travel across space
really appeals to me
[Music]
certainly the whole issue of
contamination by alien bacteria i think
it's
the one thing
we can't protect against it's what we
saw in the history of recent history of
humans as we've gone across through the
world spreading things like smallpox so
in a way that's a study a miniature of
what would happen perhaps if an alien
culture were to come here we're going to
need some sort of galactic quarantine
yeah or a galactic hospital
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video